Baba Yaga a very popular and intriguing
figure in Slavic mythology translated
her name roughly means elderly woman or
grandmother but don't let this fool you
as tales of Baba Yaga have terrified
children for years at first glance you'd
be forgiven for thinking Baba Yaga was
an ordinary witch she does not ride a
broomstick nor does she wear a pointed
black hat she's often depicted as a
small elderly woman with a large
distorted nose and long iron teeth her
clothes are often rags and very unclean
baba Yaga can fly using her giant pestle
and mortar with her broom made a silver
barge to sweep away any trail she may
have left behind some say at Baba Yaga
is the devil's grandmother implying that
at some time she may have had children
of her own in most variations of the
tale she lives on the edge of the forest
in a wooden hut however this is no
ordinary house as it is supported by two
giant chicken legs and can uproot and
move whenever needed it has no windows
and often the door can only be revealed
once it is told a magical phrase turn
your back to the forest your front to me
the picket fence around in the house is
made from human bones with skulls on top
to warn off anyone who may dare to enter
it has been rumoured that Baba Yaga only
eats children however she has been known
to eat strangers who have been unlucky
enough to become lost in her forest
despite her appearance and demeanor baba
yaga is not considered entirely evil
there are stories where she kidnaps
misleads and even eats children but
there are also stories where characters
have been known to seek out Baba Yaga
for her knowledge and guidance seeking
out Baba Yaga is often portrayed as a
dangerous act as she will ask visitors
if they came on their own accord or if
somebody else sent them however there is
only one correct answer
some people believe for every question
Baba Yaga is asked she ages one year
which could explain her reluctance to
help however this process can be
reversed with a potion she makes from
blue roses some people believe that Baba
Yaga can't control the weather it is
said you can tell when she is near
because the wind whistles and the trees
howl Baba Yaga also has many servants
that do her bidding the most well-known
of these being the three horsemen
whether you believe Baba Yaga is an evil
hag who feeds on children or a wise old
crone the story is one that will
continue to intrigue and terrify as
always if you've enjoyed this video then
please go ahead and leave it a like as
it helps a lot if you have anything
you'd like to add or discuss then please
go ahead in the comments below if you're
someone who grew up with the tales of
Baba Yaga I'd like to hear from you what
she evil or was she good if you feel
like this video has earned your
subscription then please go ahead and
hit that description button and stay
tuned I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained
you